so my name is Cole fury and I'm a
postdoctoral fellow in theoretical
physics at Trinity Hall University of
Cambridge
so the short answer is that the auto
neons are this special number system in
pure mathematics and the opto neons
could be important for particle physics
because they seem to mirror the behavior
of certain elementary particles under
the strong and electroweak forces so the
real numbers are the numbers that you're
used to using in everyday life they span
from minus infinity to plus infinity and
they include numbers such as 0 1 2 3 4
and they also include other numbers like
irrational numbers like the number of pi
so we say that the real numbers are one
dimensional because we can lay out all
the real numbers on an infinitely long
line now the octo neons are not
one-dimensional it turns out that the OP
twenty ones are eight dimensional and
they also have some curious properties
so for example the real numbers are
commutative so that means that that a
times B is always equal to B times a but
this isn't always true for the octo
neons also the real numbers are
associative and what that means is that
it's a a B and C like this where you
multiply the a and the B first is always
equal to a B C like this where you
multiply the B and C first but this
isn't true all the time in the octo
neons now it turns out that thanks to
these unusual properties of the octo
neons you can show that the octo neons
are able to describe the behavior of
certain elementary particles under the
strong and electroweak forces